I'm retired from being a monkey a
dancing monkey
congratulations simplexity 1111 yeah
yeah how are you feeling what inspired
this oh this is the perfect expression
of the future that I want to carve out
with my career this is long form deep
discussion meaningful the tagline of the
show is it's anything but small talk so
I'm thrilled I have experts from across
sectors coming in and helping simplify
the complexities of life which is where
we get the word simplexity
and it's been a joy this is a space for
curiosity contemplation and meaningful
sometimes difficult conversations in the
trailer you said this is going to be
meaningful but difficult sure sation yes
can you elaborate on that like what are
we tackling whatever gray in on oh there
is no shortage of topics that are on the
outside of maybe mainstream conversation
so for example I'm bringing in a
genomics expert and we're talking about
preventative medicine and then I have
someone who's helping reposition Africa
in the tech race and we're talking about
you know colonial influences and there
there are conversations that will have
so many perspectives that are different
from my own but that's the point is to
stand in this really you know grey
intersection yeah and allow people to
impart what they know and then continue
to you know foster that dialogue and for
me what I'm far more interested in is
creating an atmosphere of curiosity and
contemplation we don't need more dogma
we don't need more doctrine yeah we know
how society loves to put on the
constructs so we want to free people not
bind people that's another tagline yeah
right the first three episodes are gonna
come out at the same time kind of tease
what those
yeah so the first episode I have a
technologist who was born
she's Senegalese and now stays I think
in Britain and she's in the UK and she
was sex trafficked as a child didn't
learn to read or write until age 16 but
is now teaching 1 million women and
girls how to code to reposition Africa
in the tech race and then the second
episode I have Jackie Lopez who's one of
the og hip hop heads here who's born in
East LA and we talk about culture arts
education the the political and
socio-economic movements that helped in
birth hip hop and how to contribute to a
culture without appropriating it and on
the third episode is with a personal
mentor of mine and we'll be uncovering
your own unconscious biases and how to
understand your worldview how to dissect
spirituality how to challenge religion
are you the one that's coming up with
these people are you going out to your
friends and people that you know that
could be maybe see Missy Elliott or your
former co-stars come on Sammy Lovato
yeah we have some messages out to the
people you just listed so hopefully they
will be on the show I was actually just
talking with Shaquille O'Neal a couple
days ago and he and I worked together
years ago on several projects yeah he's
hopefully gonna come hang out it's
imperative that I don't just Center
people who already have influence and
and all of the attention so but there's
a blend of stories and if and when I do
have someone like Demi someone like
Shaquille on the show I'm not really
interested in talking about things
they've already discussed so new things
to the extent that they're willing to
dive deep I'll probably hit them with
questions they've not been asked before
what questions have you not been asked
before that I might learn about you
through this oh my gosh okay for example
I brought a sexologist a sex therapist
onto the show and I'm sharing a lot
about my history and my relationship to
my body sexuality
growing up in the church and having
a lot of shame around just being a
sexual being and and I flat out like let
you know you know the prudishness in
childhood and the transition and
discovering my relationship to my body
so there's a lot of vulnerability um but
because I produce edit direct write all
of it I have control over what the final
Burbage will be so I know okay I'm doing
this at my own discretion
hmm and I know that people will disagree
I know there will be hostility there
will be a ton of feedback both positive
and negative but there's no reason for
me to keep it within if I know that it
it may help unlock something for someone
you know anything you don't want to
share or that are sort of wary about
putting out there yes all the time
you know I struggle to give my opinion
on a lot of matters in an episode you'll
hear that I'm quick to observe someone
else's but shy when it comes to putting
anything in concrete you know what
because I I don't want to cement an idea
and project my own belief onto someone
but I do think I'm also finding my voice
and finding the strength to to say you
know I actually do have a stance on this
because I've spent so many years being
so overly politically correct that you
know I've stood for nothing right so now
I'm like yeah it's time to stand for
something but still figure out how you
can bridge the gap so as many people can
hear you as possible I don't I don't
like alienating people yeah I feel like
we did this interview a few months ago
or earlier this year and I had a million
views and people are very invested in
your stories why do you think people are
so curious about you and your story oh
no I think they're curious about
themselves and they think they're
craving depth and I by no means a
perfect poster child for either
I'm simply walking the walk and the best
way that I can and I think it's
interesting because we're not talking
about the latest and greatest trend
right now we're talking about real
things that affect us developmentally
and our relationships and
you know now I can say I'm in the
business of human flourishing but you
know I think that kind of communal
conversation is intriguing for people
because they're heard and when you
follow me you're not
there's no illusion of separation right
like you're not following a leader
you're we're friends and we're
communicating and I ask you questions
you answer and I listen yeah I can learn
from everyone who follows me so I don't
yeah I think that's just a different
it's a different dynamic and it's
refreshing for people like the same way
that it's refreshing for me you know Lee
oh my god yeah yeah I have no facade to
uphold anymore yeah and I know again I'm
gonna mess up and make mistakes and
it'll be public but hopefully if I
operate from the standpoint of being a
student the same with simplexity having
the experts share their wisdom then I
can say I'm still learning the second
that I claim to be the Guru is the end
of my career you know now you're always
about as people I think he is evolving
we're always learning talking about sort
of your upbringing and what you've been
through and I mean you have been through
quite a lot how do you feel like your
past sort of got you to this moment and
made you want to be so vulnerable and
yeah it's a matter of feeling like even
within my family dynamic at home you
know a lot of children do not feel like
their needs are met their voices are
heard did you not feel that way um with
my with my home we had so much going on
at all times and I was working you know
I was performing at the age of three so
you had so many different outside
breadwinner by the way um when I
I was helping support my family my
parents both worked but there are a lot
of layers to a child being responsible
for you know being rapidly adult if I'd
even if it doesn't translate to you know
the financial status of the family it's
still a matter of showing up to work
becoming the boss and then going home
and
having to remember it's dirty thank you
oh yeah yeah so it's a very it's a very
difficult and complex relationship I
think for parents and children in
entertainment the parent doesn't want to
upset the child because the child has to
show up to work but the parent doesn't
want to enable the firmness the kindness
the love the you know priorities it all
it's so easily convoluted yes but and I
you know I'm writing my book on the
psychological impact of child stardom
and but I'm providing hopefully
solutions in there too because I want to
create courses for people who are like
insanely talented and creative and want
to pursue things professionally or they
have a talented kid and they're
charismatic and precocious and you
automatically assume you've got to
commodify it and put them in commercials
and I want to be able to break down like
check in with yourself know where you're
coming from and then these are the risks
this is what this industry looks like
it's how it works and like proceed with
caution yeah be bold have fun but also
know as a parent you are responsible for
a lot of the repercussions and and they
are preventable so you think the
hardships that maybe you went through
that guide you to this point where you
want to be more vulnerable and open and
hopefully people can learn from you kind
of stem from the family dynamic more
than anything else um I think it was
reverberate it everywhere so it was with
family and it was with career a sense of
not having a voice so now I'm asserting
myself I mean learning to speak up I'm
learning to you know dictate that the
path of my my future narrative and I
think what's most exciting is that when
you break past the molds the societal
constructs that's when the fun starts
yeah because you're not your identity
isn't dependent on thriving in them and
finding your status and worth within
them so now I feel like I can dance in
and out I can dabble when I want to with
entertainment
but I also have a very strong compass
that exists outside of it well I should
say deep within and isn't shaken and
stirred by the industry strong
boundaries oh very important yes so
important
yes so important will you act again
oh what a deep question I mean
technically I'm on five shows right now
so I can't claim that I'm not acting I'm
mostly animated that's what I was gonna
say because you have the Phineas and
Ferb show yeah that one's not on
currently
um but roundhouse unscrews yeah if it's
the right story I mean I can let you
know that I have plenty of things
cooking and I thankfully will also be
considered the creator and executive
producer and not just the person showing
up hoping you hire me mm-hmm I think we
take the lean away the proach now we
reposition ourselves because we all need
to play the game the whole idea of an
entire system thriving or relying on
millions of people who are so talented
and uniquely individual flocking to a
city to compete for us like a small
number of opportunities at that we're
over it you also have your youtube
series alchemy which is amazing and I
watched a recent episode and it was sort
of about finding healthy partners and
maintaining healthy relationships yeah
is that gonna be a topic that you also
discuss on the podcast oh of course
yeah and it's gonna be interactive so
whatever people listening want to hear
I'll dive in but I will say if you're
looking for the basic response just
google that and find it on Wikipedia
because I'd rather provide you
information that's a little left of
center not politically we have to
clarify that now but but something
that's gonna be a little more creative
and and requires you to to get more of
your gears going you wrote this
incredible essay for Teen Vogue where
you talked about your own sexuality and
you said as a child star people said
don't come out it's gonna ruin your
career
right how do you feel like that affected
your career yeah so it has definitely
affected in positive and negative ways
it's a mixed bag I would say Society has
shifted so much in ten years that when
that was first a conversation it might
have been more of a negative threat now
on the flip side people are exploiting
the queer community right and you're
looking at like creating more products
and services targeting queer people just
so brands look you know impossible and
inclusive right now
yeah I'm not I'm not fooled so I think
now it's just a matter of making sure
when I do talk about that with my
audience it's not also only in tandem
with me selling you merchandise that has
rainbows on it it's very much like I
want you to be able to find a safe and
comfortable atmosphere to talk about
these things no judgement and also I
don't need your wallet to get involved
right are you dating right now yeah do
you have a partner oh and you liked it
though I mean I would like to know I
have really wonderful people in my life
always always good connections at least
adjacent to the industry but also people
who know nothing about what I do that's
the past I was gonna say I feel like
that's important to sort of have hey
this is me in front of the camera and
then yes is my personal life we're on
the podcast what will you draw that line
yeah I'm not sure I don't know yet and
I'm perfectly okay with saying I don't
know I think it'll evolve as I deepen my
roots and what I'm okay and not okay
sharing but um I think what's exciting
is the more I learn about myself and the
longer I have to digest it the more
comfortable I am sharing it with people
I don't I don't need to be this
completely private person but you know
there are other layers involved being in
the public eye there are safety risks
too just like word vomiting what's
happening in my world on a daily basis
yeah and I get that what is the toughest
thing to share isn't that hmm my love
life uh-huh
what's the toughest thing to share oh no
I think it's the taboo topics that
people don't know how to talk about so
it's politics its religion its sexuality
I would Oh God
love to have some live episodes that are
panels where I bring in people from all
different points of view on a matter and
we hash it out together
yeah in a respectful manner because
that's the kind of like nitty-gritty
dialogue that I like I think what I'm
hoping with the podcast is that we not
only help people look inward and
understand their themselves we also help
them understand what's happening in the
world and I think you know there's that
whole concept of like spiritual
bypassing where you go okay you know I
don't see color I don't I'm we're beyond
that this happened centuries ago let's
move on and it's like no no you have to
deal with what's there first yeah you
have to become healthy with you know
healthy relationship to your past self
your present self so that the future
self can be free if you try to deny any
of those elements they'll just show up
in your body and in your life in
different ways later how do you keep
yourself healthy after having gone
through so much yeah um I'm have a
different method of decision making now
so I have to write it down but health is
a huge factor and whether or not I say
yes to a project and I'm working with
the coach because I need so much help
with this it's so easy for me to just
work or work work work all the time but
my coach is helping me create stopgaps
like actual legitimate criteria if the
opportunity doesn't check yes to these
six things it does not go on your plate
anymore and that's really hard to be
that stringent but it's it's highly
personal and and I know deep within that
it also reminds me okay this is the
future you're trying to mold to yeah
it's not just like you don't want to
work hard it's like you're invest you're
deliberately creating space so something
new can emerge and if you don't do that
you will stay in
read forever right and it's also you
don't want to do things that might be
triggering right oh yeah yeah a while
ago I actually I talked to Demi Lovato
not to bring it back to that but I said
like do you ever still feel triggered
and she said yes and it's kind of like a
difficult thing so I'm just curious if
you ever feel that way well it would be
very silly of me to claim that I am NOT
triggered when first I'm human
secondly being in the public eye I have
people sending messages all day long
that are speaking to my past right and
I'm sure she does as well everyone does
even if you're not in the public eye
when you speak with your family or
friends they speak to who you were
yesterday often times not always instead
of speaking to your highest version
speaking to your future and so that's
the kind of relationships and community
I'm wanting to build with my online
audience just so people don't glue me or
themselves to past narratives because
that's where the triggers will recur
right or it's unnecessary triggering
right Lennie of things in life will
already present the opportunity to be
reminded in your body you don't need to
add insult to injury yeah speaking of
your online audience I noticed on your
Instagram you do these like inclusive
alliance what inspired that it's are you
talking about accessibility yes so
credit goes to my audience the
accessibility text is simply to allow
people who are visually impaired to use
text-to-speech apps so they can hear
when when they read the caption they can
hear what's happening in the video I
love that you do that oh it's it's I
feel like more people should probably
start yet you know way honestly should
be the baseline
yeah so that everyone can experience
social media you are one of the most
thoughtful people I think would like
your advocacy and even this
accessibility text text and what you're
doing with this podcast you ever feel
like you're doing too much yeah her up
video okay yeah totally yeah I'm a
trialed star in my past life right so
everything I learned was to appease
to get approval and to try and be
everything to all people so a part of my
journey now is knowing where I draw the
line in the sand like I am truly doing
my best to be inclusive to be diverse
not just racially but also neurodiverse
bringing people in who think differently
who will respond differently to my
questions but at the end of the day I'm
now able to go all right I truly did my
best I can let it go and people's
feedback will be what it'll be yeah
is there a dream guest oh you will you
come on the show I'll come on the show I
love to because I'm gonna ask you all
these questions it's hard it's hard yeah
I mean it's not hard for me to ask
question no but hard to be honest and to
be honest yeah I'm gonna grill you I'd
love and yeah we would what would you
ask me um probably things that you're
not allowed to say on your on your job
okay
what's the hardest question you voted
now she just went next I'm just gonna
put it to the left yeah you do that
sometimes
absolutely yeah you have to do that
we're Jedi's yeah what do you see for
the next five years for yourself ah yeah
so I wanted to get into offering more
products and services and not that you
know are super expensive but creating
tools and resources and courses that
people can with the click of a button
have access to maybe they they can't
afford full-on therapy and by no means
am I gonna treat cure diagnose anything
but if I can supplement your personal
transformation I would love to try my
best
just for cancer for child actors um so
for for my audience as well as young
performers I think we'll probably start
either with with you know like a mental
health for artists and creatives
specifically or mental health kind of
supplementary kit for whoever comes to
my page I'm also working on some mindful
movement courses that integrate for
people who can't of you know can't
afford to take an hour out of their day
to workout and an hour to meditate and
an hour to journal
could we create something that is almost
like a fitness alternative or you mean
connect everything and approach your day
feeling balanced yeah using my dad's
background so somewhere dancing in
future Oh dancing reimagined I don't
need to hit a one-two step not real yo
y'all can google that first as long as
you need to get that hit of nostalgia
it's there for you on YouTube we can we
can graduate do you consider yourself
like retired from dancing um no no I am
retired from being a monkey a dancing
monkey okay yeah so now if and when I do
it it's on my terms thank you very much
I think that's great yeah more music I
have you know albums and albums worth of
songs that I'm not sure I'm not sure
I'll release them yet there are so many
other important conversations happening
like the podcast and the music will
happen music will happen when it when it
needs to happen
[Music]